die cdu in sachsen anhalt will auch
wegen dieses videos nun die geplante gz
erhöhung stoppen genau darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen
mit sven schultze es nicht zugeschaltet
und cdu generalsekretär in
sachsen-anhalt sagen wir was genau regt
sie an diesem video so auf hallo also
dieses video ist ja nicht nur für mich
sondern viele menschen aber ganz
speziell für die polizisten und deren
angehörige in deutschland absolut
inakzeptabel hier sind polizisten die
als rassisten dargestellt werden als
mörder dargestellt werden und das ist
ein bild was hier von der deutschen
polizei gezeichnet wird und mit gebühren
der beitragszahler mit ard und zdf
gebühren letzten endes bezahlt wird
das ist für uns und für viele menschen
in deutschland inakzeptablen das ist
auch einer von vielen anderen gründen
warum wir in sachsen anhalt auch schon
vor längerer zeit gesagt haben dass mit
uns die nächste gebührenerhöhung nicht
geben wird heißt ganz konkret sie wollen
jetzt diese erhöhung stoppen rechteck ja
es ist ja so dass in den landtagen das
ist nicht nur in sachsen anhalt so
sondern in einen anderen landtagen auch
jetzt über die gebührenerhöhung das ist
ein prozess der schon länger läuft
beschlossen werden muss
wir haben bei uns im koalitionsvertrag
drinstehen dass zum einen der
öffentliche recht öffentlich rechtliche
rundfunk natürlich unverzichtbar ist das
ist ganz klar
aber wir wollen beitragsstabilität haben
das steht bei uns im koalitionsvertrag
drin
daran werden wir uns als cdu halten und
deshalb kommt für uns dieser geplante
gebührenerhöhung nicht in frage das
würde am ende bedeuten wenn es diese
mehrheit in sachsen-anhalt gibt und
danach sieht es im moment auch aus im
landtag dass die nächste
gebührenerhöhung damit erst mal nicht
kommen wird
das bedeutet nur in sachsen anhalter
nicht oder heisst es 1 1 landtag den
ganzen widerspricht liegt die erhöhung
generell auf eis nein es müssen alle
landtage zustimmen damit die
gebührenerhöhungen kommt ein landtag in
dem fall hier in sachsen anhalt
widerspricht und da gibt es im moment
nur die grünen und die spd die dem
zustimmen würden
dann liegt die gebührenerhöhung auf weiß
es gilt dann für ganz deutschland
genau wie diese entscheidung gefällt das
wird in den nächsten monaten sein da
gibt es eine
stimmung es gab ja eine abstimmung unter
den ministerpräsidenten die das in die
wege geleitet haben
das ist erfolgt bisher und jetzt sind
die landtage dran es ist aber auch schon
vor längerer zeit uns angekündigt wurden
und auch gegründet worden mit der
beitragsstabilität und auch damit
begründet worden dass mir sagen
die gebühren müssen einfach auch nicht
nur transparent sein sondern auch
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden und da sind
wir der meinung dass es in der
vergangenheit immer wieder gründe gab
das ist nicht der fall ist deshalb ist
es jetzt nicht nur aufgrund dieses
videos sondern es gibt viele weitere
gründe auch dafür